[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL JACKSON: This project
is, in a sense, an MIT project
through and through.
It's about MIT.
It was produced at MIT.
It was funded by MIT grants.
But in some sense, I think
there's nothing about MIT
here at all.
This is a universal project
about a universal problem.
But I have to start by telling
you a little bit about MIT
and where this
project came from.
So as many of you probably know,
MIT's a rather quirky place.
It's probably one of the
only universities that
has an annual piano
drop, and this
is a picture I took of
the piano drop in 2015,
and there is the
piano about to fall.
And MIT is a quirky place, full
of fun things and fun people
mostly having a good time.
But it's also a
highly competitive,
high-pressure environment.
I'm sure none of you have
ever been in a place like that
before.
And that can exact its costs.
And in 2014, 2015 we had a
terrible mental health crisis.
That makes it sound as if
it came out of the blue.
The truth is it had been
brewing for a long time,
but it really came to
a head in that year.
In 2014 in particular, four
students took their lives,
and my colleague Seth
Teller died that summer too.
At the same time, there
were smaller crises
happening everywhere-- just
the burden of depression
and anxiety at MIT was
increasing year by year.
And I had noticed
this in my courses.
I would have, typically, when I
started teaching, maybe none--
maybe a couple of students who
had some issue during the term.
By 2014, 2015, I was often
having 5 or 10 or more students
coming to me during the term.
They would normally come and
say that they wanted help
with a problem set, and then
once we sat down and talked,
it became clear that they had
no difficulty understanding
the material.
They had no lack of talent.
They were just suffering
from, basically,
a major episode of
anxiety or depression
that was preventing them
from doing their work.
And this is actually a
shot of my office window
in the lovely Stata Center.
And so this got me thinking
about how pervasive depression
and anxiety at MIT had become
and how big a problem it was.
And then in the spring of 2015,
when this photo was taken--
as you know, this is what spring
often looks like in Boston--
it was a really terrible time.
In a week in March 2015, two
students took their own lives
in the same week.
And the shock of
these two deaths
really galvanized
the entire community,
and the MIT newspaper published
a series of articles--
a remarkable
editorial-- about how
it was time for us to
face up to this issue,
but also two articles
in particular that
really struck a chord with me.
One was this article--
a guest column by a sophomore
called Karen [INAUDIBLE]
about her own
experience with dealing
with her own depression.
The other was an article
by Professor John Belcher,
that it was actually
republished--
it had actually been
published previously in 2012,
and that article had been
inspired by an article,
I think, in 2010 by a student
whose name was Grace Taylor.
And one of the things that I
noticed about these articles
was that they produced
an extraordinary wave
of consolation--
particularly in
the student body,
but I think in the
institute as a whole.
And there was something
just incredibly reassuring
about people
standing up in public
and saying this
is a real problem,
and I've experienced
this problem
and I've grappled
with it, and I'm here
to tell you that I came out
the other side of the tunnel.
It's possible to do that.
And this got me thinking.
It got me thinking in particular
about how important it
was that they had their
names on these articles.
I suspect at Google,
too-- at MIT,
we have what you might call--
what I like to call a
geek libertarian culture,
and that culture often
puts what I think
is actually an inappropriate
value on anonymity.
Because a lot of people are
very concerned about privacy,
they think anonymity is
somehow a good thing in itself.
And what I noticed was that when
people used anonymous forums
to talk about things that
they weren't happy about,
it didn't have this
consoling effect.
And I came to actually
think that perhaps it had
exactly the opposite effect--
that there's actually
something that
reinforces stigma about
expressing yourself
anonymously.
Anyway, so like many
other people at MIT,
I was wondering
if anything could
be done to respond to
these horrible tragedies
and to do something
to help our culture.
Anyway, so as [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned, I'm a photographer.
And every summer, I'd
been going off to Maine--
to the Maine Media
Workshops up in Camden,
which is this fantastic
place that has--
I don't know-- 30, 40,
50 photography workshops
every summer.
They last a week long,
and you study them
with one photographer and
it's a remarkable experience.
And I'd been going
for many years,
and that summer I studied
with a photographer
called Joyce Tenneson.
And one of the great things
about these experiences
is that you learn not only
a lot about their style
of photography and
their aesthetics
and the way they go about
constructing an image,
but you also get to learn about
their life and the way they
think about their career.
And Joyce said something
that was really remarkable
and that really
struck me very deeply.
This is a picture I took
of Joyce that summer.
These are pictures that
Joyce is famous for.
She'd been a commercial
photographer,
and then she had really moved to
becoming a very successful art
portrait photographer.
She produced a book
called "Light Warriors"
that these photographs
were taken from.
And as she put it, she came to
realize that she was spending--
or had spent--
much of her career
making photos of beautiful,
young women in their 20s.
And it suddenly
occurred to her that she
was a woman in her 70s--
early 70s, I guess.
All her friends were
in their early 70s.
And yet she was still taking
pictures of women in their 20s.
And it occurred to her that
maybe what she should do
is take pictures of beautiful
women in their 70s instead.
And so what she did
was she did a project
that she called "Wise
Women" where she traveled
across the country,
and she took pictures
of women between the
age of about 50 and 100.
And she produced that book,
and it was a huge success.
In fact, by her telling,
it was the biggest success
of all her books.
This anecdote really
got me thinking,
and I started wondering
who are my wise women?
As a photographer, if I
was going to come home,
as it were, and find the people
who were my obvious subject
rather than going to the
traditional art subjects,
what might that subject be?
And I realized--
well, that subject
would have to be
people at MIT who
were in the midst of this battle
against depression and anxiety.
So I came back from this
workshop totally fired up
with this idea that I was going
to do a project where I would
make a gallery of photos of
people who had experienced
depression and anxiety.
And my idea was that by
showing this gallery,
it would signal to
people that this was not
something to be ashamed of.
On the contrary,
this was something
to be proud of-- to have
faced this enormous challenge
and to have endured it, and
become even enriched by it.
And I hope that
in so doing, this
would bring some consolation
and encouragement to people
who are suffering
from these conditions,
and it would also destigmatize
it for everybody else to see.
And I also had this
feeling that these people
had something to teach
us all, because one
of the ironies of the way
that we'd been thinking
about mental health is
that a lot of people
were talking about mental
health, a lot of the experts--
the psychiatrists,
the psychologists,
the anthropologists and so
on, and the administrators--
but the people who actually
experienced depression
and anxiety, they
didn't seem to be
playing a part in this
conversation at the institute
level.
So I wrote to the
three people who
had published those articles--
Karen the sophomore, John
Belcher the faculty member,
and Grace, who had written
the original article.
She'd moved on to
Harvard Med School.
And I asked the three of
them if they'd be Guinea pigs
and if they'd let me
take photos of them
as the beginning of a
gallery of photos of people.
And to my delight, they
accepted very enthusiastically.
So I started by making
a photo of Karen,
and my original idea was to
make environmental pictures--
whatever part of MIT they chose.
And that turned out to
be a pretty crazy idea.
This was taken in the
library, and it just
wasn't the right kind of
private, quiet atmosphere
to do that.
So I switched to doing more
traditional studio-like shots.
So this was the photo that
I ended up making of Karen,
and I took photos of
the three of them.
And then at the end of--
that was 2015.
At the end of the
year, with the help
of some extraordinary
undergraduates,
we pitched to "The Tech--" which
is the MIT school newspaper--
the idea of doing
a series in which,
every week, we would put
up a picture of somebody
and an excerpt about their life.
And I should say originally
I was going to just
have a little caption
associated with the picture,
but as soon as I heard Karen's
story and the remarkable things
she had to say, I
realized that there
was an opportunity, essentially,
for a whole mini biography
here.
So that's what the
project became.
It became, basically,
a portrait in words,
and a portrait in an image.
And at the beginning,
I was excited about it,
but I have to
admit-- having agreed
to produce one every
week of the term,
you can imagine I thought-- wow,
that was a pretty crazy thing
to do.
What the heck was I thinking?
They'll never come.
But they did come.
And in fact, enough came not
only to publish one every week,
but to get a few that I didn't
even have room for in the term,
and that's eventually what led
to this book that you've seen.
So typically this is
what would happen.
I would take a photo.
This is the wonderful
Victor Morales, whose story
is completely remarkable.
And then the MIT newspaper
published the photo.
They usually gave us a full
page, which was wonderful,
with the story around it.
The story is an entirely
verbatim accounting
by the subject.
It was only minimally
edited by me.
I basically recorded the story--
I recorded their words, had
them transcribed, and then
just minimally edited it,
removing "ums" and "ahs"
and punctuating it,
and occasionally moving
things around to preserve
the chronological order
of the story.
But aside from that, every
word in these stories
was spoken to me.
And then what I did
was I put up posters
all around campus that said
if you have a story to tell,
please come and tell it to me.
And lots of them came.
And by the end of
that first term,
I'd interviewed 18 people,
which included mostly students--
interestingly, mostly
women-- a couple
of professors, and a bunch
of administrative staff.
So that was what
happened that term,
and then I decided that I--
actually, to be honest, I
had hoped from the outset
that this would become
a book, because I
had a sense that this
was something that
could be valuable beyond MIT.
And so I proposed this
book to The MIT Press,
and they agreed to publish it.
I was very lucky that
two MIT organizations
helped fund this project.
As a photographer, I wanted
to have a lovely book printed
on very nice paper with a
very nice binding and so on,
and that's incredibly expensive.
So the book probably should
have cost $60 or $70,
but the MIT Council for the
Arts gave me their biggest grant
of that year.
And then I got another grant
from the MIT MindHandHeart
Innovation Fund,
and that allowed
us to subsidize the printing so
much that the book is actually
relatively cheap--
I think very cheap by the
standards of this kind of book.
So they're typically going
between about $20 and $30
a copy depending on Amazon's
current algorithmic state.
And then a wonderful thing
happened the following--
actually, this was
before the book came out.
An alumnus approached
me and said
that he was very
interested in giving
the book to new students
at MIT, and he proposed
running a Pi Day Challenge.
That's our MIT annual
fundraising day.
And we ran that
challenge collaboration
with MindHandHeart, which
is the mental health
initiative on campus, and
amazingly raised about $15,000
that day.
And that was enough
money to buy a copy
of the book for every student.
So we gave a copy of the book
to every incoming student
the following year.
And since then, it's been a
really fun and exciting project
of basically taking
these remarkable stories
of these extraordinary
people on the road
and trying to
proselytize for the book.
We've had some wonderful
media engagements.
And what, for me, has been
particularly wonderful
is that on every
occasion when I've
been invited to go
somewhere, I've always said,
well, want my subjects, not me.
And so they've
always come with me.
This is in the BUR studio
for "All Things Considered"
with Lisa Mullins, and
that's Emily Tang and Victor
Morales, who are both
extraordinary people.
And actually, BUR
then played it--
"All Things Considered" was
just a local production,
but then they actually played
it nationally on "Here & Now."
So that was really terrific.
And then we had a really
extraordinarily exciting
opportunity that "PBS NewsHour"
decided to come to MIT
and talk to us about the
story, and they actually
played two long segments
two nights in a row.
This is the
classroom I teach in,
and here are three of the
students being interviewed
by Jeff Brown, the
arts correspondent.
We also had a very entertaining
interview with Jim Braude,
who some of you might know
from "Greater Boston."
He's also on an NPR
show with Margery Eagen,
and he's a very funny guy.
This is Haley on the left.
They're cracking up
after she calls him sir,
and he exploded in amusement,
claiming that nobody had ever
called him sir before.
And I'd like to show
you a little video
in which the subjects
speak for themselves.
It starts with audio
excerpts from the interviews.
And as you'll see, people
really said some amazing things
about their life experience.
And then it includes some
photographs that I took during
the sessions-- many of
them not in the book--
along with excerpts--
verbatim excerpts--
from what they told me
during the interviews.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I committed a week before.
I said yes to MIT, and then
she has this heart attack
in front of me.
So I went through with my plans.
This is what I'm
doing in the fall.
I'm going to college.
And people die all the time.
Everyone has to deal
with their parents' death
if they have parents.
This is something
I can deal with.
And I think that was a mistake.
- Especially because
when someone dies,
you don't know, necessarily,
until they're dead.
You just take for
granted everything
that they had been holding up.
- So over those
next two days, I was
feeling absolutely terrible.
I had [INAUDIBLE] to do.
I was already
getting really down,
and I really wanted
to commit suicide.
And I just said this to the
guy I was doing therapy with.
And he was like, hm, I'm
going to have to go talk
to someone about this.
And as soon as he said that,
as soon as he left the room,
I'm like, fuck.
I'm getting transported.
And sure enough, I sent
a message to Danny.
I'm like, Danny,
I think I'm going
to get sent to [INAUDIBLE].
- He stood at the
foot of my bed.
He had a clipboard,
a stethoscope.
He had a main tank,
a white coat--
all the accoutrements
of authority.
And he said, Mr. Kaiser,
your operation was a success.
But I'm sorry to tell you
that you'll never walk again.
Now, when he said that to me,
what I said inside my head was,
fuck you.
What I said to him was,
I'm sorry to hear that.
- The big goal was to walk.
And I remember when I
first stood on my legs,
my hamstrings hurt so bad.
- I always knew there
was something wrong.
There's a better way
to live than this.
I just didn't know where
it was or who knew that.
I just knew that I just
felt crappy all the time
when I was a kid, when
I was a teenager, when
I was a young adult.
- And then I went
to my therapist
and I said, is this how
normal people feel every day?
And she said, yes.
And I said, well, I had no idea.
- My medication mellowed me out.
And it was a good thing,
because I wasn't having
the extremes of the depression.
So it helped me survive.
- The most useful thing
I learned from being away
was that you can
always ask for help,
and there will always be
someone to help you here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DANIEL JACKSON: So I wanted
to close by telling you
a few things that I
thought I learned from what
my subjects taught
me, and then talk
about what I think some
of the implications
are for a place like Google.
So the first thing I
learned from talking
to all these people is how much
unhappiness is in the world.
And I was reminded of this
remarkable comment from
the Hasidic master, Rabbi
Nachman of Bratslav--
who's widely thought to
have been bipolar himself--
who basically said that
the principle that we all
have to deal with is to
struggle with all our strength
to be happy.
That happiness is
not a natural state,
but it is human nature to be
drawn to darkness and sadness.
And sadly, I think,
that's really true.
And so happy people aren't
people who are just lucky.
They're people who work at it.
The second thing-- which you
won't be surprised to hear--
is that competition
really hurts.
Everyone told a story of coming
from a high school where they
were the top of 1,000
students, and they come to MIT,
and they're just the
same as everybody else.
You hit MIT, and it's
not enough anymore.
I learned that depression--
that major depression--
depression is really
on a spectrum,
and that major depression is
a terrible, terrible disease.
I mean, I knew already that it
wasn't just like being a little
bit unhappy, but the people who
suffer from major depressive
episodes go through
something that many of them
describe as much worse
than physical pain.
And it's a terrible and
debilitating disease
that robs you,
more than anything,
of your resilience,
which makes it very hard.
I learned that relationships--
for all these people,
they all explained how their
relationships to other people
were really at the
center of their recovery,
and Lydia in particular
said this remarkable thing,
which has stuck in
my mind ever since.
She said you don't
realize what people
are doing in your life,
what roles they're playing,
sometimes, until they die.
And you don't know what
you're holding together
in other people's lives.
You might not know that you're
the glue holding together
so much, because you
take yourself for granted
like we take other
people for granted.
So anyway, there are
many other things
that I learned from
the book, and I
hope you'll get a chance
to read the stories.
I think they all have
really remarkable insights
into the nature of
life and diversity
and ideas for how
to achieve happiness
in the face of obstacles.
I want to say a few things
about resilience at work.
The first is that these
conditions, if we're just
talking narrowly about
anxiety ans depression
and bipolar-- these
are universal.
And so this is just
applying the normal rate.
So if I'm assuming an almost
90,000 people at Google,
that means you have about
18,000 people at Google who
have a severe anxiety disorder,
about 7,000 who've experienced
major depression,
and about 3,000
who have bipolar disorder.
So this is basically everywhere.
It's pretty clear what
causes depression.
We don't know, in any
individual, what the cause is,
but in pretty much
all my stories,
there's some combination of
a genetic predisposition,
traumatic experiences, and
then a stressful life--
not enough sleep and exercise,
poor social connectivity,
and ultimately a
loss of self-worth--
which seems to be the trigger
that, for a lot of people,
really takes them to
a quite ruinous state.
So I've thought a little
bit about strategies
for resilience.
First of all, to
value the whole person
and to be very careful
about judging people
on one dimension--
the way they perform
on the team, what their program
ability is, whether they're
intelligent only in a logical
sense rather than their larger
emotional intelligence.
Secondly, we always
pay lip service
to rewarding the team
players, but do we really
reward the team players
who actually build up
the other members of the team?
Who aren't just
team players because
of their outsize
contribution to the end
result, which is
different from really
building the team itself?
And I think one that I've
come to realize more and more
as really critical is
that an organization needs
to encourage people to be
able to acknowledge and talk
about their own vulnerabilities.
A friend of mine,
who's been educating me
in organizational
matters, shared with me
this extraordinary paper.
It's quite old, and I
think it's from 2014--
by Robert Kegan and his
colleagues at Harvard Business
School.
And the contention
of this paper is
that if an organization
actually encourages people
to be open about
their vulnerabilities
and their weaknesses
and their obstacles that
sit in front of them,
then it will actually
be able to dramatically
not only change
the environment in
the organization,
but also to give people
opportunities for growth
and improvement in their
lives and their careers
that they wouldn't have
had in an organization that
tends to want to
smother any talk of all
these vulnerabilities.
And this, to be honest,
is the biggest flaw
that I see in our
culture at MIT.
We're always rah-rahing
and saying we're so great.
We're so amazing.
We have all these
cool inventions.
amazing people.
And the truth is
that can actually,
ironically and paradoxically,
be a very negative message
to a lot of people, because
the first thing it says
is if you're not on this list of
people who have been mentioned
as the great,
fantastic people, then
there must be something
wrong with you.
But it's also
saying subliminally
if you feel, in any respect,
that the environment isn't
perfect and that
you're not perfect
and that you can't see a
direct path to huge success,
then there must be something
very wrong with you.
And that doesn't empower
people to be their best,
and that doesn't actually
create an organization in which,
rather than feeling jealous
or disappointed and angry
and bitter about not
being the best achievers--
it doesn't create an atmosphere
in which people can actually
work together to
achieve great things.
On the subject of
team players, I'm
reminded by this
wonderful comment
that Jerry Weinberg made--
famously-- in his old
book on "The Psychology
of Computer Programming."
And he was talking more in
the context of programming
in its various
problems, but I think
it applies very much in
the emotional sense of team
players.
And here's what he said.
He said if a programmer is
indispensable, get rid of him
as soon as possible.
And I think the only
way I would update
this is by saying get rid of
him or her as soon as possible.
But in every other
respect, I think
this is just as powerful and
relevant as it has ever been.
Strategies for
personal resilience--
I think people have obviously
written a lot about this.
To me, there are three that
I found particularly helpful
and that, reflecting on
what my subjects told me,
I think were influential
in their lives.
One was to know what
your purpose is.
And in particular,
for your purpose not
to be a particular GPA or
getting a particular fellowship
or getting your internship
at Google in the summer
or getting a certain promotion
or having a certain salary
or being at a certain
rank in your organization.
None of those are a purpose.
Those are all means to an end.
And if you can have a real
sense of what your purpose is
in life, that's a much truer
way to resilience and happiness.
The second thing
is that people who
are open to other people
about their own fears
and vulnerabilities
end up being,
I think, much happier and much
more resilient themselves.
Partly because they
share the burden,
partly because other
people respond in kind,
and they realize
that the world is
both a more vulnerable
place, but also
a kinder and more supportive
place than they imagined.
And I think the other thing
is that one of the things
that we all do--
well, I won't say we all
do it, but I've certainly
done enough of it myself--
is we all play certain parts
and we all try and pretend,
to some extent, to be
people that we are not.
And particularly if
you're the kind of person
who works for Google or MIT, you
could get pretty good at that.
And then if you're
intelligent, you
can sometimes play that game.
But ultimately it comes back to
bite you, because ultimately,
if you don't project yourself
for who you really are,
then there will come a
point at which you're
doing things you don't want
to be doing and presenting
yourself in a way that
doesn't feel right.
So I thought I
would ask you-- what
do you think the biggest
challenge is that you face
in the tech industry at
Google, or societally,
organizationally,
and personally,
and what are the best strategies
and opportunities to address
that?
I'll just show my
last slide, which is--
I have a little resilience
postcard that I send out
about once a month,
and I'd be delighted
if you'd like to
subscribe to that.
And you can find out more
about the book there.
But at point, I think
I will stop talking,
and I'd love to hear from you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Doesn't quite
address your question,
but do you have plans to
continue this project,
or are you done with
this form of [INAUDIBLE]
DANIEL JACKSON: I'm
trying to figure out how--
I don't think I'm going to
continue it exactly like this,
but I'm looking at
working with some people
on some exciting projects
of a similar nature.
I did a little
project, actually--
which now seems quite timely.
When the travel ban came
out I did a little project
of a much smaller project
of photos and stories
of MIT immigrants and
their life stories.
And I'm talking to some
women at MIT about,
perhaps, doing some #metoo
stories at MIT and beyond,
but we'll have to see.
I'm suddenly very
intrigued by the idea--
the role that this kind of
photography and storytelling
can play in changing
people's attitudes.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
I had a question.
You gave this book out to a
whole class of MIT students.
That's a huge data set.
Did you happen to notice
any effects of that
of increased self-reporting,
increased seeking for help,
increased freedom and peer
mentorship in the following
years when that class went on
to be sophomores and juniors?
Did they carry that on back
to the new incoming freshmen?
DANIEL JACKSON: That's
a great question.
And it was only last year, so
we don't have any data yet,
but I know that
MindHandHeart is very
interested in tracking that.
I'm not sure how this
particular intervention would
be decoupled from other ones.
I do have some anecdotal
reactions, a couple of cases
where students have sent very
moving messages to participants
in the book about how
their stories helped them--
in sometimes quite
surprising ways.
And so that's been
quite interesting.
But you're right.
You're asking a
very good question.
I don't really have a
good answer to that.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
more of the portraits that you
took were of women than of men.
Do you have any idea
why that might be?
DANIEL JACKSON:
Well, my guess is
just that women are
more open and are more
willing to share these things.
One of the very interesting
things was that the beginning
of the project, when I sat
down with John Belcher--
the professor--
who was one of my Guinea
pigs at the start,
he said to me, for old
fogies like you and me,
this is easy, because
we have nothing to lose.
We're tenured.
We can't be fired.
He said, you'll have no
trouble getting faculty.
But students, they've got
their careers ahead of them.
The idea of social
media being covered
with their early
troubles in life--
they're not going to want that.
And the fascinating thing was
it was exactly the opposite.
By and large, with the exception
of two or three people,
no faculty members
wanted to talk to me.
And I know for sure
there are many, many,
many who have experienced
depression and anxiety.
And students, completely
to the contrary,
had a extraordinary
openness and candidness.
In fact, Krista Tippett--
I don't know if you know.
She's the host of this
wonderful NPR show, "On Being."
She once commented--
actually, in an interview
with danah boyd talking about
the internet and social media
behavior-- how she thinks it's
almost a new kind of ethic
that the way young
people behave in sharing
has an openness and generosity
that's really unprecedented.
And I certainly
experienced that,
and I experienced it
particularly from these women
more than men.
I tried to, actually,
get more men.
One of my colleagues-- a
female colleague-- said to me,
it's all women.
Can't you get some men?
And I said, I'm trying.
But yeah, so I don't
know what it is,
but there's certainly a
gender difference there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I missed the
first half of your talk,
so I'm so sorry if you've
already covered this.
But how do you think that
we can teach resilience
to university students?
Do you have any
strategies for that that
work in the classroom, or
that can work in our meetings?
DANIEL JACKSON: Sure.
I think the main way that
we can teach resilience
is by example, is by the way
that we talk about the goals
that we set for ourselves
and for each other,
and by making a culture in
which we actually value openness
and encourage people to
share their struggles,
with the idea that that's
the way you become better.
Just one thing that
occurred to me--
I realized that for
a long time, I'd
been saying we should value
people for who they are,
not because they've
won certain prizes
or have certain possessions.
And then one day,
sitting in a lecture,
seeing someone introduced,
the person said, and I'd
like to introduce you to my
colleague so-and-so who's
won A, B, C, and D prizes
and whose article is
the most cited, blah,
blah, blah and so on.
And I realized I've
done that myself,
and that completely
undermines any claim
that these proxy measures don't
matter when you're constantly
sending a subliminal
message to the students
that actually, these are
the things that count.
And so I think we
need to change the way
we talk about these
things and I think
we need to try and value people
in a much more holistic way.
I think that would produce
the biggest effect.
I think we also
somehow simply need
to crank down all the pressure.
I'm not sure how to do that, but
we certainly need to do that--
give people time to mull
things over a bit more.
AUDIENCE: One of the
things is by the time
they get to college, there's
already some processes in place
and some experiences that
these kids have, and is there
any things that you guys are
looking into around earlier
experiences that can help
students coming in already
prepared with resilience?
DANIEL JACKSON: Whoa,
that's a great question.
I don't know.
Yeah, I'm not part of the team
that worries about this at MIT,
but I think you're
absolutely right.
It's often well-established.
But in my experience talking
to the subjects of my book,
it's often in early
childhood that they
had traumatizing experiences,
and those experiences then
come up much later.
They get triggered by their
experience in university
or in the workplace.
And so I think you'd
have to go way back.
So I suspect we also--
I mean, I have a--
and I'm sure you've read
the famous Jean Twenge
article in "The Atlantic"
about mobile devices
and those extraordinary
graphs that
show the advent of the
iPhone almost perfectly
correlated with huge
drops in social activity,
whether it's driving
cars, going out
with friends, sexual
intercourse-- everything
plummets in 2009 with
the advent of the iPhone.
And just anecdotally,
I think a lot of people
are feeling that devices
are a very large part
of the alienation that
young people feel,
and that that's dramatically
exacerbating the problem.
So maybe as a technologist,
one of the things we can do
is work on that.
AUDIENCE: So you would
ask what does Google
do to help its employees?
And I still remember
the orientation--
that they point out
that you will feel
overwhelmed in the beginning.
This is expected.
This is normal.
Everybody gets this.
And even some points later
on, you'll get to the point
where you feel like,
what am I doing here?
And pointing out that there
is a lot of imposter syndrome
at Google, and
pointing out that it's
normal-- which is very
helpful, especially when you're
starting out.
DANIEL JACKSON: Yeah,
that's very good.
I think just setting
expectations.
I think that's one
of the things that's
very demoralizing for
people who somehow--
particularly if they came from
an experience early in life
when everything was easy, and
then suddenly it's not easy.
And maybe if they could
just be told-- maybe
we need to do a
better job of that
as well-- telling people
it's not going to be easy,
and here are the
challenges you'll face.
AUDIENCE: I know
you said you weren't
part of the overall
program that deals
with the application of
this, but have you changed
the way you teach
within your classroom
at all, incorporating
any of these ideas?
DANIEL JACKSON: That's
a great question.
Have I changed in
my own classroom?
So I have to first admit that
that makes me feel tremendously
guilty, because one of the
things that we did was we
tracked the amount
of time people
spent on the programming
assignments in my course
this term, and I don't dare to
tell you what the numbers were.
But suffice it to say it was
a classic MIT Firehose course.
Who would have thought
that learning Node.js could
take so long and then you'd
need more than three days to do
that?
I mean, who would imagine?
And it turns out you need
more than three days.
And so I think I've
done, actually,
pretty badly in my
own course-- certainly
in terms of cranking down the
pressure, and that's something
I know we really
need to work on.
I think I've become better--
I hope in a couple of respects.
One is that when a student
wants to come and talk to me,
I never, ever, any
longer say, well,
have you checked with the TA?
Because I'm worried
that they're going
to ask me something about
installing Node or something
that is really a
technical question
that the TA can do
better than me anyway.
And I've come to realize
that when a student goes
to a professor, they
have a reason they
want to talk to you,
and that often is not
what the pretext is.
I think I've also
learned that when
people come to talk to you--
I had a very MIT-ish attitude,
engineering attitude,
that you have to solve
people's problems.
So someone's feeling sad
or depressed or whatever,
you have to know what to do.
You have to say, well,
here's what you do.
Get more exercise.
Get more sleep.
Go see a psychiatrist.
Go see a psychologist.
Go to MIT Mental Health.
And I came to realize how
incredibly misguided this is.
First of all, you can't
solve their problems.
But secondly, they don't want
you to solve their problems.
They're smarter than you think.
If they wanted you to
solve their problems,
they wouldn't be coming to a
computer science professor.
They could be going
to a psychologist.
The reason they
come in to you is
because they want you to
listen to their problems.
And so I've realized
that actually, it's
a lot easier than
you might imagine.
And I think, as
faculty, we just need
to realize that sometimes
our students just
need us to listen to them
and to pay attention.
So I hope I've improved
in that respect.
But in the structural respects
of the class, I have to admit--
that needs some work.
And it's also particularly
challenging in a large class.
I think in a small
class it's a bit easier,
because you can
build relationships
with the students.
I should say one
exciting thing is
that some of the counselors
from MIT Mental Health
have been doing a freshman
seminar this fall using
my book on resilience, so
I'm very interested to see
how that will turn out.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to comment--
because I brought this
up in a Google context
before-- that I think the
partner skills or resilience
are compassion and humility.
And for people
who don't struggle
with any kind of mental
illness or barriers,
if we can teach them to be more
compassionate and more humble,
it supports the
work of the people
who need to be resilient
because of various things
they'll struggle with.
So just something
to think about.
I taught freshman CS
for a couple years,
and I specifically
worked with my students
on compassion, humility,
and resilience.
And so I think we
would all do well
to consider those three values
in our workplaces and courses.
DANIEL JACKSON: I think that
that's a great point, actually.
And one thing to mention
is that at MIT, there's
been an explosion of
these failure activities.
There was an undergraduate
one and a graduate one,
both of which I was
honored to participate in.
I guess I was honored
to be chosen as someone
whose failures were
considered major enough to be
able to talk about them.
But I think that's
actually a great move--
having people talk very publicly
about failure and about how
they've coped with failure.
And I also think it's actually
interesting pedagogically,
because I think that people
who are good at something
are normally-- it's
not that they just
have a natural ability
and they get it right.
It's that they've
actually learned
how to deal with things
when they go wrong.
I mean, that's what
crafts are all about.
It's not that you can measure
perfectly and cut perfectly.
It's that you know
how to adjust things
when things are slightly off.
And I'm reminded
of how I finally--
I had been working
with my daughter, when
she was a teenager,
for many years trying
to help her get into math.
And she was so fearful of it and
so convinced she was bad at it.
And finally, I got her to
admit that she actually
thought that if she
was good at math, then
the answers would come
back to her immediately.
She wouldn't need to think hard.
And what I explained to her
was that might be true for one
in a million, really,
really extraordinary,
off-the-charts math
students, but actually,
most of the students who
are really good at math--
they're good at it because
they're good at the thinking,
and they're not frightened
to do the thinking.
And that what she needed to
do was get over that fear
and realize that
it isn't natural.
It doesn't come naturally.
And that if you can
sit with the problem,
then you can actually
make progress.
And I think that made
some change for her.
So I think that this idea of
us all being a bit more humble
and explaining that
things are hard--
I think can also be
pedagogically very powerful
as well.
Thank you all so much.
It's been a pleasure being here.
[APPLAUSE]